DENIAL.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
SINCE GETTING BACK FROM
CHRISTMAS BREAK, HANNITY IS
TEASING ME, I HAVE TORTURED
MYSELF BY READING AND WATCHING
SOME OF THE USUAL SUSPECTS IN
THE MEDIA.
FAKE NEWS, POPULATED BY FAKE
THINKERS.
THERE ARE BASICALLY TWO
MOVEMENTS IN THE COVERAGE.
FIRST THE MANUFACTURED OUTRAGE
ABOUT WHAT IS A PARTIAL AND
OBVIOUSLY TEMPORARY GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
>> YOSEMITE, THE NATION'S THIRD
BUSIEST NATIONAL PARK, THEY ARE
ALSO HAVING HUGE PROBLEMS WITH
GARBAGE AND TOILETS FILLED TO
CAPACITY.
>> PARK VISITORS IN SOME PLACES
ARE TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS,
SHALL WE SAY, ALONG PATHWAYS ARE
IN THE WOODS.
>> IT'S IRONIC THAT THE PEOPLE
MAKING THE DECISIONS ARE STILL
GETTING PAID BUT WE HAVE TO NOT
GET PAID AND STILL DO OUR JOB.
>> IT'S GOING TO COME TO A POINT
WHERE YOU SAY DO I PUT GAS IN MY
CAR OR FEED MY FAMILY?
>> Laura: THEY HAVEN'T MISSED
A PAYCHECK YET.
I HOPE THEY DON'T.
SECOND IN THE COVERAGE IS THE
DOWNPLAYED CONCERN ABOUT THE
ACTUAL EFFECT THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION HAS IN AMERICA.
IN THE MEDIA'S WAY OF THINKING,
IT'S NOT A CRISIS AT ALL.
>> MIKE PENCE KNOWS HE WAS LYING
THROUGH HIS TEETH LAST WEEK WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT THE CRISIS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> THE POINT OF HOW THE
PRESIDENT HAD WON THE ELECTION
IF THERE WAS A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
HE HAD TO CREATE THAT SENSE OF
CRISIS TO END AND HE HAS TO KEEP
THAT SENSE OF CRISIS TO KEEP HIS
POPULARITY FROM GOING EVEN
FURTHER DOWN.
>> Laura: OKAY, I'M NOT
COMPLETELY CONFUSED.
IT'S A CRISIS THAT CERTAIN
NONESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT WORKERS
WON'T BE PAID STARTING ON
FRIDAY, BUT THEY WILL ULTIMATELY
GET ALL THEIR MONEY WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT REOPENS.
BUT IT'S NOT A CRISIS?
IN THE PAST FISCAL YEAR, A TOTAL
OF ALMOST 400,000 INDIVIDUALS
WERE CAUGHT CROSSING OR
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF JUST HOW
BAD IT IS, IN OCTOBER AND
NOVEMBER THIS PAST YEAR, THE
FIRST TWO MONTHS OF THE NEW
FISCAL YEAR, ALMOST 102,000
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CAUGHT.
THAT'S QUITE A CLIP.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE CROSSING
ILLEGALLY WITH CHILDREN HAS ALSO
SKY ROCKETED.
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY JUMPING
FROM FISCAL YEAR 2017 TO 63,278.
NOT A CRISIS?
THIS IS AND HAS BEEN A CRISIS
FELLED BY AVERAGE AMERICANS FAR
BEYOND THE COMFY CONFINES OF TV
STUDIOS AND FAR BEYOND THE
IDEALS OF CONGRESS.
YET THE MEDIA AND DECEITFUL
POLITICIANS ONLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CRISIS WHEN THE TRAGEDY OF AN
IMMIGRANT CHILD MAKES THE
HEADLINES.
>> TODAY'S VISIT REAFFIRMED THE
FACT THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
STILL HAS A LONG WAY TO GO IN
MAKING SURE THAT MIGRANTS ARE
TREATED HUMANELY.
>> Laura: YOU BET EVERY LIFE
IS PRECIOUS.
YOU BET THEY DID EVERY DEATH IS
TRAGIC.
DEATHS AT THE BORDER, DEATHS
BEYOND THE BORDER.
BUT THE FAULT HERE LIES WITH THE
RESPONSIBLE PARENTS WHO EXPOSED
THEIR CHILDREN TO THIS PERILOUS
JOURNEY AND THE FECKLESS
POLITICIANS WHO REFUSED TO DO
THEIR JOB AND SUPPORT A
COMMON SENSE ENFORCEMENT OF
GENDER THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
AND ASYLUM REFORM THAT IS BEYOND
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
OVER THE PAST YEAR, I REPEATEDLY
URGED THE PRESIDENT TO ADDRESS
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AND NOT JUST
THE WALL AND A MAJOR PRIME TIME
ADDRESS.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO ADDRESS
THIS FROM THE OVAL, AND THEY
SHOULD BECOME A FLASH POINT NOW,
NOT AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY.
I HAVE BEGGED HIM TO DO THIS FOR
A YEAR.
ON AIR.
IT'S THE GOVERNMENTS
IMMIGRATION.
THOSE TWO ISSUES ARE THE TOP OF
THE LIST FOR THE PEOPLE.
THE GOVERNMENT, MEANING WORKING
AGAINST THE PEOPLE, AND
EMIGRATION.
THAT'S IT.
YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS THE COUNTRY.
NOT TWEETS.
TODAY I AM GLAD TO SEE HE
ANNOUNCED HE'S DOING JUST THAT
TOMORROW NIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO BE FOLLOWED BY A
TRIP TO THE ACTUAL BORDER IN
McALLEN, TEXAS.
GOOD.
I WOULD HELP WHEN HE DOES THIS,
THE PRESIDENT PERSONALIZES THE
BORDER CRISIS.
THOSE STATISTICS I JUST GAVE YOU
ARE IMPORTANT BUT WE NEED TO
EMPHASIZE HOW ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION HAS DIRECTLY AND AT
TIMES TRAGICALLY AFFECTED THE
LIVES OF ALL AMERICANS AND
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE TRYING TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
IT'S BEEN DANGEROUS FOR THEM.
THE SPEECH SHOULD BE WIDE
RANGING, HITTING ALL THE BIG
IMMIGRATION ISSUES FROM CHAIN
MIGRATION TO THE VISA LOTTERY,
THE NEED FOR MANDATORY E-VERIFY
IN THE WORKPLACE, AND ALSO YEAH,
EVEN THE SCAM OF SO-CALLED
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
THAT'S WHERE CHILDREN OF
NON-U.S. CITIZENS ARE GRANTED
AUTOMATIC CITIZENSHIP JUST FOR
BEING BORN HERE.
EVERY YEAR, THOUSANDS OF
CHINESE, RUSSIANS, AND OTHERS
TRAVELED TO THE UNITED STATES TO
HAVE BABIES JUST FOR THE U.S.
PASSPORT.
IT'S CALLED BIRTH TOURISM.
IT'S A COMPLETE OUTRAGE, IT'S
BIG BUSINESS.
NO, IT'S NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT SO DON'T TRY ME ON THAT.
FOR ALL THOSE WHO CLAIM, BY THE
WAY, THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
NOT A CRISIS, I THINK AMERICAN
FAMILIES OF THESE VICTIMS WOULD
DISAGREE.
THE DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS,
CALIFORNIA OFFICER RENEWAL SING
WAS SHOT IN COLD BLOOD DURING A
ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP.
HE LEFT BEHIND A WIFE AND A
5-MONTH-OLD BABY.
HIS MURDER, ILLEGAL ALIEN
GUSTAVO PEREZ ARRIAGA.
THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS AND
HUNDREDS OF OFFICERS ATTENDED
THE FUNERAL SERVICE.
I WISH ALL YOU CAN WATCH IT.
THIS HAPPENED OVER THE WEEKEND.
THIS IS THE FIJI AMBASSADOR, THE
OFFICER ORIGINALLY HAILED FROM
FIJI, SPEAKING AT THE SERVICE
AND I WAS WATCHING THEM TODAY.
I HADN'T SEEN IT UNTIL TODAY.
HE HAS A BETTER GRASP OF THIS
TRAGEDY THAN MANY AMERICAN
COMMENTATORS.
>> NO WORDS CAN TAKE AWAY THEIR
PAIN.
NO OBJECT CAN FILL THE VOID IN
THEIR HEARTS.
NO EMBRACE CAN BE MORE
COMFORTING, NOTHING CAN REPLACE
THEIR SHATTERED DREAMS.
NO DEATH CAN BE MORE UNTIMELY.
THIS IS WHAT ROB O'NEILL SINGH'S
PASSING MUST MEAN TO THOSE
CLOSEST TO HIM.
>> Laura: HIS PARENTS ARE
STILL ALIVE AS WELL -- STILL
ALIVE AS WELL.
THERE WAS A COLLISION IN
KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE.
THE MAN WHO SWERVED INTO HIM WAS
ANOTHER ILLEGAL ALIEN.
MY FRIENDS, THE FAMILIES OF BOTH
OF THESE UPSTANDING AMERICANS
ARE TO 19 CRISIS.
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT RELENT.
HE MUST CONTINUOUSLY FOR THESE
FAMILIES AND FRANKLY FOR THE
MILLIONS OF YOU WHO BELIEVE THAT
EVERY COUNTRY, NOT JUST OUR
COUNTRY, EVERY COUNTRY AROUND
THE WORLD HAS THE SOVEREIGN
RIGHT TO DETERMINE WHO CAN AND
CANNOT RESIDE HERE.
IT'S NOT A MORAL TO DO SO.
IF OUR ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
REFUSED TO DO THEIR SOLEMN DUTY
TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY, THEN WE
IN ESSENCE, WE KIND OF ALREADY
HAVE A GOVERNMENT THAT IS SHUT
DOWN.
SHUT DOWN TO THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY, THE PEOPLE ROUTINELY
RANK ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS ONE
OF THE MOST URGENT PROBLEMS
FACING THIS NATION.
AS FOR THE REPUBLICANS ON
CAPITOL HILL, THINK ABOUT IT FOR
A MOMENT.
TAKE A LESSON FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY NEVER BREAK RANKS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU REPUBLICANS
ACCOMPLISHED BY SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT DURING THE
CONFIRMATION FIGHT OF BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
WHEN THINGS GOT TOUGH AND THE
MEDIA WERE PILING ON,
REPUBLICANS STOOD FIRM.
DO IT AGAIN HERE.